meditation is a very complicated thing
uh it's
every person you talk to who meditates
will give you a different almost
definition different observation
different what it's good for uh
different how you do it so what i'm
telling and some people like koppel
who's kind of my coach guy hates it okay
he hates the whole concept of meditation
but i'm going to tell you my version i'm
going to tell you what i learned that
worked for me um first i'm going to
back up a little bit uh but there's a
meditation master here we're actually
all meditation masters so my meditation
is no better than yours i'm just telling
you mine um
so
but it's so
let's think about how how your mind
works okay when you're walking down the
street your mind is usually associating
it's in free association so it's
basically saying oh this woman just
crossed the street with a dog oh i used
to have a dog just like that oh when i
had a dog like that i lived in that
apartment oh that apartment god that guy
overcharged me oh i hated that guy so
your mind is always just free
associating and connecting things around
you and having sort of this
uncontrollable stream of thoughts
that's like kind of like your default
how your mind operates
beyond that is contemplation
contemplation is when you sit there and
you direct your mind to one topic to one
subject
scientists are essentially in
contemplation they're working on a
specific problem a poet when they're
like trying to figure out the right
words for the poem you know they're in
contemplation
sometimes an author can be in
contemplation when they're plotting out
the narrative for their book
next beyond that is concentration
concentration is when your mind is
focused on one thing
and
this can be you know you're surfing and
you're riding a wave uh you're driving a
car at a high speed around a bend uh it
could be you're having sex with somebody
your mind is focused on that act
so concentration is when your mind is
single pointed most meditation
techniques are concentration methods and
there are many many meditation
techniques if you ever want to run
through a bunch of them you can pick up
a pick up a book called the book of
secrets by osho
and i know he's gotten a bad rap
popularly uh recently but he was he was
a pretty smart guy
but this is a book called the book of
secrets by osho and it's actually a
translation it's a translation of an old
i believe sanskrit book that has
something like 120 different meditations
in it and you can try each one you can
just see which one works for you
the one that works best for me is the
fourth state of mind so concentration
what you're trying to do either with a
mantra or watching your breath is you're
trying to bring your mind to what's
called a single pointed state and then
once it is focused on this one object
that is concentrating on your mind is
supposed to disappear it's supposed to
basically drop the mantra or drop the
breath watching on its own without
effort
and your mind is supposed to stop and
then you have a chance to see what
you're really like underneath underneath
this anxiety
filled barrage of thoughts that you're
always happening having
so the last thing that you're trying to
get to the last stage after
association contemplation and
concentration is meditation
meditation is the art of doing nothing
you cannot do meditation
by definition if you're doing something
you're not in meditation meditation is a
state you're in when you're not doing
anything when you're not doing anything
physically when you're doing anything
mentally when you're not doing anything
consciously you're just making no effort
you're literally being completely still
physically and mentally inside and out
that is a state that you're trying to
achieve but there is an oxymoron which
is for true meditation you're not even
there the thing that's trying to achieve
the state of meditation cannot actually
be there in full meditation so the the
method that i learned
was basically that you just sit there
and you close your eyes and for at least
one hour a day you surrender to whatever
happens you don't make any effort
whatsoever you make no effort for
something you make no effort against
something if something travels through
your mind then you let it go if there
are thoughts that are running through
your mind you let the thoughts run
what's kind of going on is that your
entire life things have been happening
to you some good some bad most of which
you processed and resolved but a few
that stuck with you and over time they
stuck more and more with you and they
almost became like these barnacles stuck
to you uh and you lost your childhood uh
you know your childhood uh sense of
wonder and being present and being happy
you lost your inner happiness because
you built up this personality of
unresolved pain and errors and fears and
desires that are glommed onto you like a
bunch of barnacles and now how do you
get those barnacles off of you how do
you strip them off of you well what
happens in meditation is when you're
sitting there and not resisting your
mind these things will start bubbling up
it's like a giant inbox of unanswered
emails tens of thousands of emails going
back to your childhood and they will
come out one by one and you will be
forced to deal with them you will be
forced to resolve them and resolving
them is doesn't take any work you just
observe them but now that you're an
adult now that you have some distance in
time and space from previous events you
can sort of just
resolve them
you can be much more objective about how
you view them someone just mentioned
peyote yes that psychedelics are a bit
of a cheat code in this although i don't
recommend drugs for anybody because i
think you can do it all through pure
meditation if you wanted to accelerate
ahead you know psychedelics are good for
that
there's a there's a good book that
michael pollan wrote recently called how
to change your mind and i think that is
a brilliant book that everybody should
read
in any case so with meditation over time
you will resolve a lot of these
deep-seated unresolved things that you
have in your mind and it is different
for everybody and once they're resolved
there will come a day there will come a
day when you sit down in the morning to
meditate and i recommend morning one
hour a day because anything less is not
enough time
to really get deep into it but
i would recommend if you really want to
try meditation do 60 days one hour a day
first thing in the morning and if you if
you sit there
do that after about 60 days
you will sort of be tired of listening
to your own mind you will have resolved
a lot of your issues or you have to hurt
them enough that you will know you have
kind of seen through those fears and
those issues and what will happen is one
morning you're gonna hit mental
inbox zero okay if you know the inbox
zero concept is when you open your email
and there are no emails and it's zero
email and that is a pretty amazing
feeling uh that is a
now i don't wanna describe this because
it's kind of nonsense to to use these
descriptions for other people but it's a
state of somewhere we enjoy and bliss in
peace
and once you have that you don't want to
give that up if you can get a free hour
of bliss every morning just by sitting
and closing your eyes that's worth its
weight in gold that will change your
life
in terms of uh how to sit still for an
hour by the way meditation isn't hard
all you have to do is sit there and do
nothing just sit down close your eyes
and say i'm just going to give myself a
break for an hour this is my hour off
from life this is the hour i'm not going
to do anything yes if thoughts come
thoughts will come i'm not going to
fight them i'm not going to embrace them
i'm not going to think harder about them
i'm not going to reject them i'm just
going to sit here for an hour with my
eyes closed and i'm going to do
nothing how hard is that why can you not
do anything for an hour
what's so hard about that just give
yourself an hour break that's it uh the
book i mentioned was michael pollan
p-o-l-l-a
he's famous for being the new york times
uh
i think he's a new york times uh
journalist and he wrote in defense of
food and the omnivores dilemma
and this is his most recent book
i actually don't recommend the apps i
love what the headspace and com guys are
doing and i'm a big fan of them but for
what i just described that method will
not work with an app because the app
will clutter your mind with the
instructions from the app no music no
noise no sound just sit in a quiet dark
place put your back against something if
it's the first thing in the morning
you're not gonna fall back asleep so
it's okay to lean you don't need any
fancy postures or poses you just need to
sit down such a way that you're
comfortable so put pillows underneath
your knees
you know put big cushions underneath
your butt whatever it takes gets super
comfy because you don't want to move for
the next hour you just want to relax
completely and do nothing all you're
doing is giving yourself one hour off
i think the apps are great training
wheels but you know at some point you've
got to learn how to ride the bike
someone asked can you talk about going
through and resolving those thoughts um
the thoughts resolve themselves i know
that sounds hard to believe but you just
kind of have to sit there with them
that's all the reason they don't get
resolved is because you're running away
from them because you're fighting them
if you sit there with something long
enough it will get resolved i mean
listen
all day long
there are things that bother us and
those things sit in front of us and
annoy us until 10 minutes later they're
gone and the next thing is bothering us
so when you sit with something long
enough it does go away it's not like it
stays there forever but some things just
take more time but there's nothing to do
other than just to let it be just let it
let it come up just watch it let it be
[Music]
how do you know you've hit inbox zero oh
you'll know it's not subtle when you hit
inbox zero then meditation arrives when
meditation arrives this is a whole
different beast my drug of choice
honestly these days is meditation
somebody asked me my drug of choices i
like red wine i won't lie uh and you
know living in california we've all
tried cannabis here and there but
meditation is it that's that's my main
drug of choice that's the one that i get
high on every day
what is the noise behind you it's a
fireplace
someone asked does seeking inbox zero
defeat the point of it
yeah i mean in some very deep sense yes
like for true true meditation you can't
have an objective you can't be seeking
anything but i assume i'm talking to a
general audience here not to advance
practitioners for a super advanced
practitioner
you don't want to seek anything but it
it is kind of contradictory it's like
well then why sit down and meditate in
the first place
you can sound really clever by saying
you know there's no point to it you're
not supposed to do anything and there's
no reason to do it nor should you seek
it but then you actually wouldn't do it
so it would defeat itself if you defeat
yourself at the starting line
now you've done almost like 100 plus
podcasts probably 150 episodes okay so
now you have an uh wide enough like
sample cystic to see of these successful
people are you seeing commonalities as
that is leading to their
success in their careers i think there
are a few things that come to mind right
away the first is
now this could be a selection bias maybe
i'm choosing people who are
more prone to have certain things in
common than others or i'm attracted to
people
in a way that uh that biases this but at
least 80 percent
of the people i've interviewed across
all domains have a daily meditation
practice of some type
[Music]
certainly if you want to cut down on
monkey mind the first step is just to
become aware of it and kind of observe
it like a really shitty comedy
in your head just like what is my brain
doing this doesn't make any sense
uh and
20 minutes in the morning is a great way
to do that and i'm not particularly
um
i'm not particularly in favor of one
versus another i found tm transcendental
meditation to be very helpful because
it's presented in a very secular way and
i find the white noise of a mantra the
word mantra bugs me so much but a word
that you repeat over and over again to
be very helpful
but vipassana there's a there's a good
book called waking up by sam harris sam
harris whose phd in neuroscience has
been on the podcast and talked about
this tara brock also fantastic 80 plus
percent have some type of meditation
practice even if they don't call it
meditation
so i've i've for instance interviewed
amelia boone incredible endurance
athlete the most successful female uh
endurance uh athlete and obstacle course
racing in the world but also in like
2012 at the world's toughest mudder i
think it was about 1200 competitors
night probably 90 male she came in
second place out of everybody that's a
24 hour race i mean she's super tough
and uh you know she said well i don't
really have a meditation practice and i
was like what do you do when you're
running and she's like i either listen
to like one track over and over again or
i sing one track to myself over and over
again i was like well that sounds a
whole hell of a lot like meditation to
me
and
then arnold schwarzenegger for instance
this was a really cool example he did
he does everything 100 arnold like when
he goes he really goes
and he did i think it was transcendental
meditation for a year
and then he felt like he hit a certain
plateau in the benefits and he stopped
but he said that the benefits persisted
for decades
very very cool
idea
uh
you know the pro the possible the
prospect of that is very exciting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you